-So congratulations
on "The Alienist."
This is your first foray into
multi-episode television.
Did you enjoy it?
-I did. I really did.
It was, um, one of the best
working experiences
I've ever had. It was almost
seven months in Budapest
and just working
with the best people, so...
-You have
very intricate costumes.
Very beautiful costumes.
-Yeah.
-They also look brutally
uncomfortable. Is that true?
-[ Laughs ] I'm sorry, Michael,
but yes, some of them were.
-Yeah. Well, I don't blame
today's modern costume designer.
I blame the turn of the century.
-Totally. No, but they were --
I mean, I hesitate to even say
that they're costumes.
These are real pieces
of clothing
that could have been worn
in 1896.
You know, it was like if there
were 50 buttons down a dress,
then they weren't, like, "snaps"
to like cheat it, you know?
-[ Laughs ]
-It was 50 buttons, and, um,
but I became, like, I had
the same costumer
every day who would get me
dressed and undressed.
Her name was Dora,
and the second they were like,
"Okay, Dakota, you're done."
I was like, hat off, handing it
to Dora. Like jacket off,
like pin off, tie off.
Like, I knew exactly
what I could take off
and just would leave
this little trail from the set
to the trailer.
Like... [ Laughs ]
I was taking off each piece
because it's one of those things
that you know when you have to
be in it, you're fine,
but the second that you know
that your requirement
is finished, it's, like, okay.
-Yeah.
-Well, it's gotta come off
right now.
-No, well, also you're like,
"oh, I'm a crazy person
dressed from
a hundred years ago."
-Yeah, exactly. Exactly.
-And you actually, you play
a fictional character, but based
on a real woman who was
the first woman who worked
in the NYPD.
-Right. Yeah.
-So that must have been
a cool person to try to embody.
-I mean, yeah.
When I read the character, I was
so thrilled to play someone
who -- she was the first woman
to hold a title
at the police department.
In that clip you saw,
she's the secretary
to the police commissioner,
who's Theodore Roosevelt and,
um, you know, but even that's
not good enough for her,
you know what I mean?
She has such aspirations to even
be more than just a secretary,
but that's sort of her way
into this world
that isn't very welcoming
to her.
-I want to ask about this.
You have an Instagram,
a private Instagram account.
[ Laughter ]
-And you brag, you're very good
at using -- you're good
at Internet stalking,
and it's so nice of you to brag
about this, 'cause a lot of
people would keep that secret.
[ Laughter ]
So what do you use --
-You've, like, blown my cover
right now.
-Yeah, I know, but, like,
so what do you -- how do you use
Instagram to find out --
like, 'cause you're a bit
of a detective.
You're like your character.
You're getting
to the bottom of things.
-Yes. Yes. Well, yeah.
There are times when you have to
go deep into -- you know,
before, you could search
people's --
who they followed at the top?
-Yeah.
-Now you can, like, put in
the first letter,
and all the B's will come up.
-Yeah.
-It didn't used to be that way.
You used to have
to scroll through,
somebody follows 523 people.
It's like scroll
through 523 people.
But sometimes that was the only
way to make connections,
you know, like...
-Gotcha.
What were you trying to connect?
[ Laughter ]
-Well...uh, you know.
-You were like, "there's
been a murder, Instagram."
-Yeah, exactly.
You know, when you just feel
somebody's lying to you...
-Oh, gotcha.
-And you've got to get down
to the bottom of it.
-Oh, so you would, like, follow,
you'd say like I'm --
if somebody would say like,
"I'm here."
You find a connection
and then you'd find
on someone else's account.
-Yeah, and I just like to know
if I meet someone, I just like
to know, like, who they...
are friends -- I don't know.
[ Laughter ]
It makes me sound
like a big creep but --
-No, like a --
like a little one.
-Like a small creep.
-Yeah. [ Laughs ]
So this -- you are not
a huge sports fan,
but you come from a family --
-I can't say that in public.
-Okay, gotcha.
-Because my mom will, like, have
my head if you say that
about me.
-Well, would your mom admit
you are less of a sports fan
than her?
-You all are less of
sports fans than my mom.
-Gotcha.
-Everyone in this room combined
is less of a sports fan.
-And is it -- it's been
problematic --
her thirst for sports --
-This is so funny. So, um...
I'm cutting you off
and telling my story.
-No, no, please.
[ Laughter ]
-Go for it. [ Laughs ]
-I went to the SAG Awards
recently, and I presented,
and I got to wear
this beautiful dress, and I --
a few weeks ago, I wanted my mom
to come to a fitting of it
'cause my mom -- she loves
clothes and fashion.
She has a great eye, and I like
her to come with me sometimes
to the fittings.
And so I had a fitting,
and I was like, "oh, we have to
be at Samantha's at 1
for that dress fitting."
She's like, "okay, okay."
You know, that day rolls around,
and she's like... [ Sighs ]
"Dakota, that is
the Georgia-Alabama game."
I was, like, yeah. Okay.
Like, I gotta --
I'm here for, like, a day.
I have to do it that day.
She's, like, "who would plan
anything today at 1 P.M.?"
[ Laughter ]
She was, like, mad at me.
-Yeah.
-Like actually mad.
I was, like, "there's nothing
I can do. I...
It has to be this day."
So she didn't come.
-Oh, wow.
[ Laughter ]
That's great. And I guarantee
the people at that fitting
also did not know it was
the Alabama-Georgia game.
-They didn't.
-Yeah. [ Laughs ]
Congratulations...
-Thank you.
-...so much on the show.
It's lovely having you here.
-Thank you so much.
-Dakota Fanning, everybody.